this is steven lara in february 2021 he
was on his way from texas to northern
california to visit his daughters but
before he could reach his destination he
was pulled over by a state trooper for
driving too close to a tanker truck on
the highway at first the trooper seemed
friendly admitting that he was actually
tasked with stopping drug and weapons
trafficking across the states he asked
even if he was carrying drugs or guns
the answer to both was no
then the cop asked them if he was
carrying a big amount of cash and that's
where things got interesting steven
admitted that he had a large amount of
cash with them and almost immediately
the trooper asked permission to search
the vehicle like any innocent person
would steven agreed pro tip don't ever
say yes to a search that search
discovered 87 thousand dollars in cash
steven's life savings
according to stephen he didn't like the
banks he even had proof that he would
drew the money from his own bank
accounts but that still wasn't enough to
the trooper and the dea agent he called
a little later it was clear steven's
money was obviously associated with
drugs how could it not be and because
the cash was connected to drugs the cops
had the right to seize it and the thing
is all of this was legal stephen wasn't
arrested or charged with a crime no
drugs were found in his car but as long
as cops suspect that your property like
a pile of cash was involved with a crime
they can take it no questions asked
i just want to just tell you officer
brother
you're taking money out of my kid's
mouth
sorry are you taking food out of the
kids man like like i said we we believe
right now that this is drug process
currency well i'm gonna prove to you
that it's not perfect thanks to some
neat laws called civil asset forfeiture
this is nasir geiger he stopped to say
hi to a friend at a mcdonald's in
philadelphia little did he know his
friend had just been arrested for drug
possession minutes after driving away
from the mcdonald's he was pulled over
by the cops his car was searched and
even though no drugs were found his car
and the 580 dollars in his car were
taken why because the cops have found
empty ziplock bags no drug residue no
drugs just plain old empty ziploc bags
so they took the entire car in the cash
in exchange nasir got a receipt for 465
dollars in the end nasir had to take a
plea deal pay a 200 fine and commit to
20 hours of community service he was
never charged he didn't even have any
drugs on him and yet if he wanted his
car back he would have to pay 1 800 in
storage fees money he didn't have
surprise surprise he never got his car
or his money back instead his car was
likely sold at a police auction where 80
percent of that money went right back to
the same police department that arrested
him
then there's mandrell stewart he was on
a date with his girlfriend when police
stopped him took him to a nearby police
station and took his 17 000 in cash
money he was supposed to use to buy
supplies and equipment from the
restaurant he worked at every single day
cops steal money cars and even houses
without charging people with a single
crime all because that property is
suspected of being involved in a crime
that is all it takes for cops to take
your stuff between the year 2000 and
2020 cops have seized at least 68
billion dollars in property from people
just like you that is more than two
times the size of the economy of north
korea and most of the time the people
who got their property stolen by cops
never get it back instead your stolen
money is used to fund police salaries
equipment and margarita machines this is
not a joke
civil asset forfeiture is a great racket
it is the closest thing to legal robbery
as it gets and as an ambitious cop from
an underfunded precinct
this is how you take advantage of it
[Music]
if you're watching this channel you're
probably ambitious and want the most out
of life and part of that pursuit
requires leaving a good first impression
and part of making a good first
impression is having a full head of
healthy hair the only problem is two out
of every three guys experience
significant hair loss by the time
they're 35 and according to my youtube
analytics that's creeping up real quick
for a good chunk of you and the longer
you wait the more hair you are never
gonna get back but lucky for you that's
where keeps comes in keeps is a
one-of-a-kind online subscription
service that gives you affordable access
to fda approved hair loss treatments
right to your doorstep here's how it
works you head to the link below then
you choose the plan that best fits your
hair situation a licensed doctor will
get in touch online to make sure you're
getting everything you need and nothing
you don't and then you set it and forget
it every three months keeps will ship a
tailor-made hair care package right to
your doorstep ready to use and then you
start using it while tracking your
progress online and you get instant
access to your doctor thanks to online
doctor messaging and all of this is
available at up to half the price at
what you would pay at a pharmacy because
they use generic versions of fda
approved hair loss medications
everyone is different but most people
start seeing results with keeps in just
four to six months so it's important to
act fast the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you can save hair
loss stops what keeps if you're ready to
take action to save your hair go to
keeps.com jtram with the link below to
receive 50 off your first order that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com jake trent or click
the link below thanks to keeps for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
every civil asset forfeiture is a good
score you are making money whether it's
fifty dollars or fifty thousand dollars
but for an ambitious cop like yourself
fifty dollars is just not gonna cut it
you're in it for the big money and the
best way to do this by stopping people
you think are associated with drugs they
don't have to be guilty you don't even
have to find any drugs on them as long
as your target looks like he has money
and is acting even a little suspicious
it is your duty as a law abiding officer
to stop and search his property so keep
an eye out for gold chains gold grills
tattoos on their faces that kind of
thing and if you're really looking to
score keep your eye on well-known drug
dealers in your city but you don't want
to stop them on their way into the city
because that's when they have the drugs
you don't get anything for confiscating
drugs confiscated drugs get destroyed so
you won't see a sense instead wait until
after the deals are done and the drugs
are sold let the drugs go out on the
streets so that your target has a ton of
cash on them and then hit them on their
way back
confiscated drugs get destroyed but
confiscated cash goes right into your
precinct slush fund ready for you to
spend and if you can't find any known
drug dealers around just target anyone
who looks like they could have some cash
who you could vaguely connect to a crime
or criminal the mother of a guy you just
caught selling weed on the side of the
road why not seize her house if he was
near it after all it is reasonable to
suspect that there's more evidence in
the house
a car driving too slow on the freeway
suspicious behavior they could be
smuggling stuff hold them over and take
them for everything they've got the list
of targets is endless and once you've
found some property right for the taking
it's time to search and seize
[Music]
here's how to seize anything you want
from whoever you want first you want to
stop them and ask some friendly
questions
some of the best places to stop and
search people are at traffic stops in
airports or even just by knocking on the
door of their house at first make it
seem like you're the good guy make some
jokes build up a little rapport then you
want to ask them if they're carrying any
guns or drugs don't ask about the money
yet once they deny having either of
those things they're more likely to
admit they have a lot of cash on them
carrying cash is completely legal so
admitting you have a lot of it isn't a
big deal right
well surprise surprise as soon as they
admit to having cash change your tune
completely spread them out no move and
if they don't admit to having a lot of
cash ask if they're willing to be
searched most naive people will say yes
to the search even though you should
never say yes to a search unless they
have a word even if they know they can
say no to a search in most people's
minds they're thinking it would be
suspicious if i didn't say yes to the
search i have nothing to hide rookie
mistake this is why you need to be
friendly the poor sucker would think
this officer is just doing his job he's
protecting the community let me help
make his life easier so they submit to
the search and you search them once you
find what you're looking for it's time
to play bad cop
this is where you suddenly connect the
dots between their property and your
made up crime you're carrying twenty
thousand dollars in cash well we see
this every day with drug dealers so
we're gonna have to seize it just to be
safe there's a packet of elastic bands
on the back seat drug dealers use those
to sort their cash so we're gonna have
to seize your car and if they don't want
to hand over their property brand to
arrest them and then reassure them that
if they're innocent they're obviously
going to get their stuff back so what's
the harm in letting you take it for now
as a precautionary measure
only a guilty person wouldn't cooperate
with the cops play every manipulative
argument in the book and once you
finally seize their cash car or house
direct them to civil forfeiture courts
where it's now their job to prove their
property's innocence
[Music]
here's the thing about getting your
money or property back after it's been
taken it's not the owner of the property
being charged is the property itself
i'm serious forfeiture cases have names
like nebraska versus one 1972 door sedan
rambler or the united states of america
versus 25 180
in united states currency the feds
aren't accusing a person of a crime
they're accusing inanimate objects
and unlike humans property doesn't get
the same legal protections it's not
innocent until proven guilty it's guilty
until proven innocence the owner of the
property has to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt that whatever the cop
sees was in fact innocence
if a cop takes someone's cash they need
to prove it's not from criminal proceeds
if the cop seizes your car you'll have
to find a way to prove it wasn't
associated with a crime knowing this
makes your life as a property season cop
just that much easier because once a
court date is set to hear why the
property you seize is innocent that's
when the real fun begins if you're smart
you'll steal from actual criminals or
poor people who can't afford the time
the lawyers or the legal fees to fight
back civil forfeiture cases can last
months if not years property owners have
to come to court over and over again
each time bringing newly requested
evidence or filing in new forms and even
if they miss just one court date they
can lose by default
eventually the process becomes so
expensive or time-consuming that most
people just give up if you seize a card
that costs three thousand dollars no one
is going to spend five thousand dollars
trying to get it back
so in the end most of the property you
seize whether involved in the crime or
not will never be returned to its owners
the perfect legal rackets and the best
part there is nothing those property
owners can do about it and now comes the
fun parts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is where you sell off all the cars
houses watches jewelry or whatever you
seize at a police auction according to
the federal equitable sharing program
your police department gets to keep 80
of the money made from selling whatever
they ceased between 2000 and 2019 that
amounted to over 8 billion dollars in
payouts to state or local agencies
who said it's only crime that pays
with all that cash flowing into your
department the possibilities are endless
sure you could use the money to pay for
offers or salaries or buy new equipment
the missouri highway patrol spent over 2
million dollars in 4 years just buying
new cars but that's not all like sheriff
bill smith from georgia you could use
that money to buy a boat a 90 000 dodge
viper or to pay inmates to build you a
party house unfortunately this is not a
joke he really did that the civil asset
forfeiture program was originally
designed to discourage crime by
reminding people crime doesn't pay that
the proceeds of a crime will be taken
away
in the words of 1da we should not let
drug dealers or anyone involved in any
kind of financial scam or ponzi scheme
reap the benefits of their illegal
actions it's a punishment i don't want
drug dealers benefiting from poisoning
children and then keeping the money
the system started with good intentions
but today it's just another reminder
that a job in law enforcement can still
be a very lucrative career just ask
sheriff bill
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you